well
that didn't last long did it
[Music]
so follow up on the uh talk shows that
were planning to resume uh without their
writers all this kicked off a week ago
when I uh well not when I talked about
it but that was the time when I talked
about it I don't want to apply to my
talking about I kicked it off but talk
about Drew Barrymore coming back and
saying that she was going to restart her
talk show without her writers because as
I clarified at the time uh talk shows
such as hers because she is not a
journalist are under wga writer skilled
of America contracts for the writers
that work on that show which means it is
a struck show it is meant to not be
getting made but she felt that it could
be made uh without input from writers
and was intending to move forward and do
so and multiple other shows followed
suit the Jennifer Hudson show The Talk
Bill Maher and they have all now
reversed course I'm gonna get a little
bit deeper into the Weeds on this but
before I do let me make this point
emphatically
this is good
this is a good outcome it's good for the
strike it's good for everybody involved
honestly it's and I mean that too for
the people who had to reverse course
they were making a big mistake not only
for the sake of other people and their
fellow union members but honestly I
think for themselves in their own
careers I think they were all making
huge mistakes so this is
now going the way that it should have
been going the whole time which is these
shows are on hold pending the end of the
strike good
this is good
we are going to dig into some more
specifics where things get a little bit
more mixed so as I said this all kicked
off initially with Drew Barrymore she's
one of two figures in this that I'm
going to be talking most about and she's
probably the one who has been talked
about in general the most and I think
that largely has to do with the fact
that she's the one who has put herself
forward the most as she said herself
when she made her initial announcements
I own this choice so she was the one in
the conversation she put out a video
because initially when she saw the
pushback she was still intending to move
forward with her plan and she put out a
video that she took down a day or two
later explaining her rationale for why
she felt this was what she needed to do
and
this has all centered very much around
her whereas say the talk and the
Jennifer Hudson show
um and even initially Bill Maher was
just kind of announced they're planning
on moving forward the even the
individual host in that show weren't
putting themselves as front and center
so Drew Barrymore is getting talked
about the most I don't think it's
necessarily because there's
um more to be said about her actions
than anybody else but there's more to
react to about her because she has
talked more she's not the only one I'm
going to focus on but this is part of
the reason why there's more stuff to
actually talk about there's more meat on
the bone when discussing this particular
aspect so again to recap she said they
were going to bring the show back
without writers
um she you know wasn't Cavalier about it
she did say like I've put thought into
this but she intended to move forward
regardless she saw the pushback put out
a video
I would say apologizing like sort of
kind of being like I didn't realize how
harsh this was for people but I still
intend to do this and giving her reasons
why and not getting the uh response she
wanted like I try not to get too deep
parsing into people's thought processes
that I can't possibly know but I kind of
suspect she genuinely thought that if
she explained herself and her rationale
that
um people would be more understanding I
think what she failed to realize is that
people weren't mad at her because of the
reason she was doing this they were mad
at the thing she was doing her rationale
didn't change the fact that what she was
doing was harmful and could potentially
undermine the strike actually we're
going to pause for a minute and tangent
on that I want to be sure that I'm clear
on do exactly how that would be the case
so broadly speaking even aside from just
being disrespectful to the writers
because a show that uses wga writers and
the wgs as on strike should not be
moving forward it just shouldn't so like
it's disrespectful to the writers but
even setting that aside it's a practical
matter it risks uh prolonging the strike
because
she and the other talk shows that
followed in her wake were going to be
producing new content which is more new
stuff for networks and Studios to be
able to put out there when other stuff
is no longer being produced it gives
them more
um basically if you were to treat
content like money it puts more into
their War chest they have more uh funds
more resources to try and wait out the
strike that's why it is important for
new content to not be made as much as is
possible with Drew Barrymore and
Jennifer Hudson and the talk and Bill
Maher they were actually going in
violation of the strike because whether
you have hired actual writers and
anyone's holding that title somebody's
doing writing
somebody has to be
um and even if you are going to claim
you are entirely improvising it which I
did a short on this but I'll recap it
real quick because the algorithm is
weird and it sometimes it treats shorts
differently from other things so I know
not everyone would have seen it but like
if you go back to 2007 2008 a number of
late night talk show hosts like say
Conan O'Brien continue to broadcast
during the writer strike without writers
and just improved everything so he had
no scripted bits and he filled up with
stuff like spinning his ring and
actually kind of drawing attention to
the fact that the show was worse without
writers now he was permitted to do that
but it was not without controversy even
at the time there were some who felt
like he was making the point like yeah
the show's worse without writers but
there were others who felt you still
shouldn't be doing it because you are
still making the point of the show could
still exist without writers but
regardless that happened then but isn't
happening now and I am 99.5 I'm sure
that it's because the strike rules this
time were written in a way to close
whatever Loop allowed for that with
Conan O'Brien last time is keep in mind
strike rules are written fresh for every
strike they are not a thing that never
changes and they use the same rules
every time so anyway coming back to it
Drew Barrymore has now said she is no
longer moving forward she was the first
one to say that she was going to and
then she was the first one to say that
she would stop and then almost in the
same order that they announced it the
first time the talk said they would no
longer go forward Jennifer Hudson said
she would no longer go forward and then
eventually bring up the rear Bill Maher
also said he would not move forward with
a new season of his show without writers
and again to reiterate that is good it's
good for the strike the strike is good
for the workers the strike is good for
the industry the strike is bad only for
uh higher up Studio execs who refuse to
take a hit to their own massively
bloated paychecks and I will not ever uh
fight for them
so hmm
um but in any case
that's where things are now I want to
talk a little bit more about some of the
ins and outs of the specifics of some of
this because I've seen in some places
where some people seem to honestly want
to hold this against Drew Barrymore and
are approaching it from an angle of well
she kind of showed us who she really was
they're kind of treating it a little bit
like a mask off from a moment or they're
taking it as such a betrayal that even
though she reverse course they're
intending to hold some degree of a
grudge
and I'm going to explain why
if you feel the need to do that like you
can I'm personally disinclined to for a
couple of reasons the first is I will
grant a personal call she had that video
that she made
um where she was explaining this was
back when she still did intend to move
forward with uh more recordings of the
show and she did uh you know that video
and she seemed very sincere she seemed
to be getting a little bit choked up you
can decide for yourself whether or not
you feel that was sincere she is an
actress it could have been a performance
I don't want to get bogged down and
whether or not it was because that
becomes a whole separate argument and
then it gets into a matter of like well
are you just never going to believe an
actor when they tell you anything do we
just assume All actors are liars forever
gosh I hope not I'm an actor
um not like a professional I ain't in
the union but still regardless I'm going
to be treating that video as if it was
sincere but even if it wasn't my overall
opinion still holds
um but your mileage may vary on that if
you believe very firmly that it was all
just nonsense
um and Bs so the thing is as I said I
think that she failed to understand
the damage of what she was doing
I think she probably genuinely believed
that if she could explain it people
would understand more and maybe she'd
still get pushed back but it would be
gentler and it wasn't and whether it was
a matter of like somebody finally
explained it to her in a way that she
got it or if she just realized the pr
mess was not going to back off and did
it strictly as a PR move to stop
I'm still disinclined to hold this
against her down the line because in her
case at least so far as I am aware and
what I have found looking into it this
doesn't feel like a mask off moment
because this doesn't feel like a
culmination of stuff that was going on
in the background like is an indication
of a general sense of privilege well
yeah she comes from a Hollywood Legacy
Family she has an inflated sense of
privilege even possibly beyond what a
lot of uh Hollywood figures do but
beyond that I it doesn't strike me as
like the moment where the mask slipped
and like oh this is who she always was
the whole time and like that can still
happen I I talked about that sort of
thing in my Illuminati video the fact
that how in contradiction to what people
thought she was her behavior was was
actually why everybody abandoned her in
Barrymore's case to me at least this
does not feel like an indication of who
she always was and it feels in
contradiction to how she generally comes
across more
um in the sense of like trying to put
malicious motivation behind her and tend
to bring back the show to me doesn't
track now again I don't know her
personally so that is me potentially
drinking the Kool-Aid a little bit on
her nice person Public Image so again
you can decide how much you're willing
to buy in on that but beyond that I'm
generally disinclined to hold a single
mistake
um against someone in perpetuity now a
couple of asterisks on that the first
asterisk being depending on what the
mistake is as I kind of said uh in a
video not too long ago
there are some things I think we can all
agree there are some things that if
somebody does that no more benefit of
the doubt now what my list of things
that qualify for that and what your list
of things to qualify for that may differ
but there are some things so that's the
first asterisk the second asterisk that
uh I am going to put on that is that I'm
disinclined to hold a single mistake
against somebody if it does not fit into
a bigger pattern so I guess less of an
asterisk and more of an underlining of
the single because there are lots of
people who will prop up problematic
media figures and go like look they just
did this one thing wrong and you're like
no this was like the 10th or 12th thing
and again at least to my understanding
what I have seen from Drew Barrymore
this doesn't feel like the latest
iteration of something that she has been
doing or has appeared to be for a while
at least it doesn't appear to my eyes
now if we get more things either said or
done by her down the line where this is
put into a context where I'm like oh
that was the start of a pattern I
reserve the right to uh revise this my
personal opinion on her but again it
won't just be one thing at that point
will it now I do still understand the
instinct to hold these things again
someone to be like well no they tipped
their hand and we should hold them
accountable indefinitely I do to a
certain extent well I don't agree with
it get that instinct because there are
times when I do apply it
I just don't do it to people I do it to
companies
because once a company tips their hand
to what they want to do and what they
want to be able to get away with and
reveal to you what they would do if they
thought it was feasible to get away with
you should always remember that and
always hold it against them especially
for as long as the same people are
running the corporation
so some examples of that
uh patreon I'm gonna bite the hand that
feeds me a little bit here a couple
years ago they were going to change the
uh method by which I think it was tax
was calculated because right now the
burden uh for tax falls on the creators
and then we're going to change it to
fall onto the patrons and that might
have sounded fine but that was going to
increase the cost of patrons and a bunch
of them were just out of necessity gonna
have to stop supporting us because
suddenly the cost of their pledge jumped
and creators told them when they
announced this plan like don't do this
we're gonna have to find other
um crowdfunding platforms if you do this
because we're going to lose so much
support and you're changing the rules on
us without consulting us so on principle
a lot of people were mad now patreon
reversed that but I think it's always
worth remembering regardless because it
still shows the kind of direction that
they would like to head and the kind of
moves that they are inclined to make
without talking to the people who
actually use their platform first an
even stronger example a couple years ago
only fans when they said they were going
to get rid of of all their adult content
despite the fact that adult content is
the reason anyone knows what only fans
is now again they did reverse course on
that but that should absolutely be
remembered because they tipped their
hand to the fact that if they ever
thought they could get away with it they
would drop their adult content creators
like that but they couldn't get away
with it I don't know if they thought
that everyone would just pivot to safe
to work stuff or save for work or
whatever but they can't get away with
that but knowing that they want to
should never be forgotten and I'll do
one more example because this is an
ongoing one Unity this is a um video
game engine that developers use to
create video games and it's been used to
create a ton of video games a ton of
small Subs ton of huge stuff be it NDB
AAA multiple massive things have used
unity and unity recently announced an
intention to put in a fee per
installation of games that use its
engines that feed to be charged to the
creators of the games now they're
already at time of recording in the
middle of backtracking and getting
wishy-washy with this because when they
initially announced it they did not
answer any of the Myriad of questions
that naturally come up from this
um nor did they uh seem to be all that
firm and really understood the blowback
that we're going to get so they're right
now they're in that oh well let us
clarify and revise the policy phase and
they might have fully backtracked
um you know within another week or so
but it should always be remembered that
they tried to do this especially
considering that they were intending to
do it retroactively and have it apply to
games that were made under the original
license agreement of using the engine
they were prepared to completely change
the terms even after a game was already
finished and made and that should never
be forgotten and there's lots of
developers who have said even if Unity
completely changes chords and doesn't do
any version of this policy we will never
use this engine again because they've
shown that we cannot trust them so I
absolutely understand and like seriously
I might need to do a video down the line
talking about the way that Services
deliberately make themselves worse and
screw over the consumer base in an
attempt to make money because they have
no way of actually maintaining their
growth otherwise I might need to delve
into that dig bigger and deeper at some
point but I need to stop that tangent
for right now but it should always be
held against corporations but I'm
disinclined to hold things to that
degree against an individual who may
have Honestly made a mistake companies
don't make mistakes they do a thing they
think they can get away with whether it
works or not you can claim that while
they made a mistake but they didn't go
whoops they knew what they were doing
human beings I think need to be allowed
to be a little bit more fallible which
is why I'm disinclined to be
particularly harsh against Drew
Barrymore at least personally there's
less to say about the talking Jennifer
Hudson because they weren't really
saying much publicly there there is a
bit however to be said about Bill Maher
so let's talk about Bill first of all
even before he announced the comingback
of his show he had already shown open
contempt to the very notion that writers
should be able to make a living he
actually said on a podcast you're not
entitled to make a living as a writer so
he actually seems to believe that people
don't deserve to make a living at their
jobs
the absolute arrogance and contempt
for people he considers to be beneath
him and for other writers is astounding
so I already had a very low opinion of
Bill Maher I also find it very telling
that he was the fourth out of four to
announce that oh yeah no we're going to
start shooting again as well and also
the last one to reverse course if I were
to guess and like I said I try not to uh
get too into
um you know sort of armed chair
psychology trying to parse individual a
person's thoughts
but I bet it was starting to feel really
lonely up on that Hill
because Drew Barrymore bailed the talk
Bell Jennifer Hudson Belt suddenly he
was the only one on that hill and I
think he realized he didn't want to die
up there
so he reverse courses well but if you're
sensing a certain amount of contempt in
my voice
it's not just because he was the last
one to reverse course that doesn't help
but it has to do with the statement that
he made my decision to return to work
was made when it seemed nothing was
happening and there was no end in sight
to the strike now that both sides have
agreed to go back to the negotiating
table I'm going to delay the return of
real time for now and hope they can
finally get this done so let's talk
about why I have open contempt towards
Bill Maher and Have No Reservations
about it first of all he has flat out
admitted the reason why he was prepared
to go bag was because he was impatient
he didn't see an end to the strike and
he was tired of waiting this special
little snowflake this little brat this
petulant child going I don't want your
weight anymore you know I try not to do
Mocking voices for anybody these days it
feels a little bit childish but you know
what screw it he's acting like a child I
don't want to have to wait anymore this
is taking forever are we there yet
well I'm I'm just gonna go my own way
and do it my ways yeah
that's what he came across like Bill
you admitted that the only reason you
were doing this and this is me taking
you at your word because it's succinctly
possible that you just don't give a crap
about anybody other than yourself and
this was the best excuse you could come
up with that you thought people might
swallow but much like taking baremore at
her word with the sincerity of her video
I'm gonna take you out your word in this
case and even if I take you out your
word it's not doing you any freaking
favors so you admit flat out that you
just didn't have the patience when you
didn't know when the end point was
because you were only willing to wait so
long you felt personally inconvenienced
you have no solidarity with these unions
you have no solidarity with the writers
with your fellow actors you have none
whatsoever no empathy no solidarity and
I have no problem saying this because of
one specific word that you use I'm going
to repeat the end of that statement and
hope they can finally get this done
not we
they
he doesn't see himself
as part of this strike he doesn't see
himself as a part or
in any kind of solidarity with the
unions he sees himself as a person
inconvenienced by the unions his success
is buoyed by members of both unions but
especially the writer's Guild he profits
from the labor of these union members
but he sees no solidarity with them not
we they those others those people those
lessers those whiny people who think
that they are entitled to make a living
doing a job
you Bill
absolutely this see this unlike Drew
Barrymore this is a case of absolutely
fitting in with the contempt that he has
openly shown to anyone that he considers
to be beneath him and people tolerated
it for a long time because a lot of his
targets were also the kinds of people
that his audience was okay being
targeted
for me honestly my Breaking Point with
him was that documentary he made years
ago religious basically just mocking
people of Faith left and right and look
I have a lot of issues with a lot of
religions and a hell of a lot of issues
with a lot of people who use religion to
justify horrible Behavior but his
absolute contempt
for the very notion of anyone who could
possibly have any kind of Faith oozed
from every single second of that film
and that was when I realized you are a
horrible person who genuinely believes
that other living breathing human beings
are lesser and beneath you and you get
away with it because you have chosen a
Target that your audience also does not
respect but here Bill your audience
at least a chunk of them do respect
writing and writers but you've shown
that you have equal contempt for them
because you consider them also to be
beneath you that they don't deserve to
make a living they aren't entitled to
make a living doing their God damn jobs
I know I said it already but
you so
yeah everybody reverse course including
Bill Maher and it is good in all four
cases including Bill Maher
that doesn't mean that I'm going to
treat all these equally
it is a good thing in all cases
I am personally of the belief that this
at least to me does not fully turn as
Drew Barrymore in my eyes I'm still
prepared to give her some benefit of the
doubt I'm not giving any to Bill Maher I
have no respect for the man he still did
the right thing by and large I don't get
too hung up
on the idea of doing the right thing for
the wrong reasons if it's truly the
right thing the wrong reasons shouldn't
matter all that much
sometimes they do though now is it still
better than failing to do the right
thing at all yeah absolutely it is still
better to do the right thing for the
wrong reasons than to not do the right
thing at all
so let's not treat it as if no good was
done in this reversal in this decision
but
bills specifically very much tipped his
hand that this was all completely
self-motivated completely selfish at
every step
he was impatient he wasn't willing to
wait now he hopes that they can sort
everything out
he thinks he's separate from it he
thinks he's above it Barrymore showed a
misdirection of her empathy and showed a
misunderstanding of the Dynamics and
that is possibly me being more generous
than she deserves I'll admit that
but I at least am willing to Grant her
uh some degree of benefit of the doubt
not bill
as for Jennifer Hudson in the talk again
the actual people Jennifer Hudson
herself in the cast of The Talk have not
really said much
Oh and before anyone asks if you were
gonna go what about the view I'm
actually finding contradictory
information about the view as to whether
or not it is actually uh a wga
production or not I've seen something
say that it's actually classified under
journalism
um because of some of the cast members
involved
um or that it's somehow a joint thing
which I'm not sure if that's a thing or
not I know the wga is still considers it
a structure at least I found sources
that said it is but The View trying to
figure out exactly what the deal with
that show is uh I I tried
I probably could have found if I put
more time into it but it was one of
those things that like I don't care
enough about this one specific instance
to do the amount of digging I'm gonna
have to do to be 100 certain about what
I'm talking about so
right now the view for me as a case of
like I really would rather you stopped
but I don't know 100 certain that it's a
scab situation just because I don't know
enough about the full details
somebody in the comments is probably
going to show me up and direct me uh
absolutely to the concrete evidence of
exactly what contract it is and because
some of you people are clearly better at
research than I am but I'm a human being
I hit my limit I hit my cap I'm like I
gotta take what I know and talk about
that and not dwell too much on what I am
unsure about so
there we go the strike continues I
continue to support it good on all four
of these shows for reversing course
though uh the minimal amount of good on
you uh being given to Bill
so what are your thoughts on this
whatever they are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my living talk to you folks about this
stuff you know I was supposed to be
backing off Wednesday videos but stuff
keeps freaking happening
ah
I'm I'm getting on a plane
at like five in the morning tomorrow
and I'm making this yeah regardless
whatever your thoughts on any of this
are drop let me down in the comments and
let's talk about it but
you know don't worry too much about it
like share and subscribe they all help
me out there's links to other things I
do down in the description don't worry
too much about all that though I
appreciate it believe me
but what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
oh
shout out to the patrons who helped make
this possible in particular I want to
thank Robin Moore Zubin fulla goddess
Elida to rock the thing that goes doing
to the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen auntie
kate808 Becky Sparks for nabilox the
poodle Robin Powell t love Tracy scrapid
angry Casper Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bennett there's being able to hear me
try and pronounce your name plus a whole
bunch of other rewards on the patreon
you can check out the tears but um
if you're already on the list thank you
so much
foreign
[Music]